[Music]
look
my nail polish matches the elevator
we're in los angeles you got a ballet
for your brunch hello everyone
today is a great day we are going to
brunch
i would do i every time i tried to flip
the floor this was just this was b-roll
oh the b-roll
it is such a nice day after it rains
it's like just
it's so clean and crisp here it hasn't
rained in a while the week after it
rains
yeah it's nice oh excellent perfect time
to hike because it's not dusty
[Music]
[Music]
well that's beautiful wow thank you so
[Music]
much
that was a super quick brunch now it's
time for me to go home
change get ready and then we're gonna go
for a hike
[Music]
seat belt safety first guys
now we're off to my house because i've
got to get ready and change
and prepare myself for this incredible
hike that we're about to do
i'm so out of shape
guys if you haven't heard the new martin
garrix song definitely
recommend it at the very start
hands on each other
[Music]
almost time for our hike um i might have
fallen asleep so i took a little nap
jenna's a little bit upset with both
matt and me
we're both not very good at doing things
and jenna is very on time and always
quite prompt what about matt and i you
say
yeah we're not quite as prompt
[Music]
oh yeah there's a lot of people here
today
you wearing your yeezy kameez sudaboos
today well not no need easy come easy
super easy come easy you know you guys
are gonna see kanye come out with the
next
line of his whatever the heck they're
called they're going to be called yeezy
kamisi some easies
and know that i came up with it i don't
know what i mean you say a lot of dumb
things but i think you
kind of just took the cake with that one
oh god usually i let you i let you rock
but
today it's not the day okay i think if
you compare the dumb things that i've
said the dumb things that kanye has said
i think he wins kanye have you
ever oh my god that came out this was a
dratini nest
so jenna and i came here to just farm
dratini we were here for like three or
four hours
uh the sun was going down and we decided
all right that's gonna be it for today
i was just tendritini's away
i'm trolling mass even though i'm doing
the same thing but then i know
everything's even
so loud she's so loud we were at the zoo
he was outside like he was outside the
girls restroom
and i was inside peeing and it echoed
entitled inside and it sounded like
him look at him look at him sounded like
he was vlogging in my ear
we are pretty loud
they changed
[Music]
get the b-roll
[Music]
if you didn't take 17 hours to edit you
could have done this all you wanted
[Music]
that just popped up in my feed trap
right here we
hunted sasquatch here matt has never
hunted
bigfoot with this one yes he has he big
bear or like arrowhead or something
it was a small hunt sure we didn't have
any gear we didn't have anything but our
last one
the last official one i think was here
with jenna marbles yeah my name is jenna
and i'm here on squatch watch i'm an
optics engineer
guys i'm really struggling
you can actually hear water here usually
you can't hear anything
or see anything it's dry
there's no use in looking back
got a life forgotten
[Music]
cause i'm so over the past
[Music]
[Music]
um
it's time for dinner now oh
sorry oh whoa
we got talking to who like people us
yeah hi hi baby oh
come on give mommy
doing what are you kisses is happening
what do you do
you need a bath baby you need to go to
the groomers
[Music]
so this is a great restaurant i love it
here everyone's so nice and friendly and
every time i come here i get a salad
and a meatball like a meatball is my
main course the salad is like my starter
i got eggplant do you think that's weird
i've got vodka
that's happy we do have some wine it's
very good
they look the same so like sometimes i
think this is water you know what i did
i only had one piece of bread instead of
like three happy baby he's fit i had a
lot well
we actually that hike was pretty intense
we've learned a lot of calories
it's growing yeah a ball of meat
literally that's
exactly what it says i didn't know what
kind i've just always been
weirded out by the idea of meatballs
like chicken farm
chicken pork with no cheese oh yeah
which is chicken and spaghetti is the
best
it's good yeah this is life
what you're looking for oh wow that's a
very hefty
you're fit they're just christmas m m's
yeah they were on sale
like february jenna and justine have
never seen
interstellar and that's what we're about
to watch we are
and i've made a demand that they cannot
go on their phones i actually have to
watch the movie because i know
how jenna watches movies what do you
think of this jen maddie this is alcohol
oh honey bear ready where's your plane
look at this can you believe what this
is it's a cake pop maker what do you
think maddie
they have cupcake maker donut maker wow
i'm getting all of them
all right so should we start watching
the movie now yes i need to set the
theme how about this
tropical twilight does that look good
look at this
oh my gosh it's so cool look at it the
little poppycorns
[Applause]
thank you movie night very nice of you
wait
oh hi maddie hi sweetie i feel like you
guys have to have seen this movie
first the next news come on it's funny
matt hates the sound of chewing i do
it's next morning oh my goodness that
was such a great movie watching our
cellar last night and watching a movie
with matt is actually terrible
he kept yelling at us if we would even
look at our phone
you're so cute anyway i'm gonna edit
this vlog i hope you guys enjoyed it and
i will see you
when i see you probably tomorrow bye
silicon
case from apple nothing too special but
the case that you guys probably saw on
my phone
and got a little bit confused is this
case
it's inside here it's called a peel case
this is not sponsored i'm not gonna say
this case is the reason that i shattered
my phone
two times in 24 hours i'm reckless yes i
was holding my dog and i
had my phone